JENNY BROWN: Welcome to Cloud
Security Basics, a series where
we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application
on Google Cloud.
Sound fun?
Then stick around.
Because in this
episode, you'll learn
about Google Cloud
service accounts
and why you might
want to be using them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PHONE DIALING]
SPEAKER: Hello, Cloud detective.
Last time, you foiled my plan
to compromise your company's
security.
But you used IAM to keep
your members identity secure
and keep me from accessing
the data I wanted.
Your employees
are secure enough,
but what about your
scripts and applications?
If the applications
that can automatically
access your resources
can be compromised,
then so can a lot of your
company's information.
JENNY BROWN: OK, so
here's what we know.
Many times, it's useful to have
an application or script that
can access resources
like data storage buckets
or other Cloud
resources on your behalf
without needing a person
to manually sign off
on the access.
One way of doing this is by
storing a user's credentials
and letting the automation
script or application use
those.
But there are a lot of
pitfalls involved when
working with user credentials.
For example, if I'm
using my user credentials
to access the resources
in my automation script,
then any time I share
access to the script,
I'll have to share my
credentials with someone else.
And this opens up
the possibility
of someone using my credentials
for something I didn't intend.
And since I'd also have to
store my credentials somewhere
for my script to be
able to use them,
this adds another security risk.
What if the wrong person
gets access to those secrets?
So ideally, I'd like
an automated way
to share access to my
Google Cloud resources
without having to store or share
my user account credentials.
Luckily, Google Cloud provides
a lot of tools and services
to protect users from
this exact problem.
And in this case,
Google service accounts
could avoid many
of these issues.
For example, instead of just
giving out my user credentials
to run workloads on
VMs, it would be better
to create a service
account for the application
and grant it access
to call Google APIs
so that users don't even
need to be involved.
Then I could grant
groups of people access
to that service account.
And this access can be
easily revoked if necessary
and doesn't involve
sharing user credentials
to access a resource.
But how should I set them up?
Let's think about this.
What else do I know about
using service accounts?
A service account
is a robot identity,
but don't tell them that.
And this service
account identity
is assigned to
permissions and roles
in order to access resources
and set credentials the same way
you'd grant access to humans.
So because service accounts
provide the same access
as user accounts, it would be
wise to significantly limit
scope and review who
has account permissions
and access to your accounts
on a regular basis.
Service accounts
don't use passwords
in the same way a
user account might.
So if you're within
Google Cloud,
then you can just attach
service accounts to instances
and other resources
within Google Cloud.
And it'll securely take care
of authenticating the identity
of the service account.
But if you're using service
accounts in another Cloud
platform or on prem, you can
use public and private keys
to authenticate those
service accounts.
And if you're using
a service key,
it's important to
not download them
because then you've gone from
an identity problem, which
is what service accounts
are intended to solve,
to a secrets management
problem like, who
has access to that key file?
And how will that
access be controlled?
This is why some organizations
set up policy disabling account
creation entirely.
And if you give an individual
your service account key code,
it's really not so different
from giving someone
your username and
password to your account.
It grants them access to
whatever you have access to.
So if we decide to
use keys, I want
to, well, one make a policy that
we store them somewhere secure
and that we don't do something
like commit the service account
credentials to the repository
with the source code, which
would defeat a lot of
the benefits of service
accounts, two, look
at key rotation.
A security best practice is
to rotate service account keys
regularly.
And this just involves
creating a new key,
switching apps to the new key,
and then deleting the old key.
But it helps a lot with
securing our credentials
as long as they're stored
and accessed securely.
Still, that doesn't prevent
the very human errors
like assigning the wrong service
accounts to the wrong users
or applications, which would
grant unnecessary permissions.
So to minimize the
chance of that happening
as much as possible,
just like with IAM,
it would be wise to use a naming
convention for your service
accounts.
It should be easy to
look at a service account
and know its purpose.
A naming pattern like
that could be effective
here as long as the
service account name fits
into the 30-character limit.
So if a Cloud team requires
BigQuery and Cloud Storage
access to automate
data uploads, we
would provision a service
account named that.
And finally, I want
to implement a policy
of tracking and logging
unused service accounts.
So hopefully, we have some
logging and monitoring set up
because a single application
can have hundreds
of service accounts if needed.
And as these
continue to pile up,
admins may start to
lose track of them all.
Maybe it would be wise to create
a policy to disable service
accounts that haven't
been used in a while
or at the least have someone
manually take a look at them
to see if they're still valid.
That's it.
I think I have enough
info to set this up.
SPEAKER: Egads, Detective.
I see you solved yet another
Cloud Security riddle of mine.
I was hoping to prey on
the automated access points
into your Cloud
infrastructure by searching
for stored tokens, passwords,
and credentials and source
repos, but I didn't find any.
It seems like
you're using Cloud--
it seems like you're
using Google Cloud service
accounts to keep
your application
secure and scalable.
Service accounts can
thwart people like me,
allow access to the right
identities when necessary,
and allow applications
to access GCP resources
without human intervention.
They make it possible to
efficiently and quickly set up
permissions, scopes, and
roles for your organization
to keep people like me out.
I hate to admit this, but you
should use service accounts
if you need to authenticate
applications or scripts to use
additional Google
Cloud Services.
You can use them to
give out permissions
across numerous
resources without having
to expose user data and possibly
negatively impact your app
security.
But you can't stop every
violation from occurring.
Be ready.
Because next, we'll
find out, what
will you do when something
sneaks past your defenses?
Hopefully, you're
monitoring and logging
what's happening in
your application,
or else you have no idea what
to do when something goes wrong.
JENNY BROWN: So there you
have it, another episode
of Cloud Security Basics.
Next episode, we'll
focus on using
logging and auditing to track
down suspicious activities.
So stay tuned for the rest
of the Cloud Security Basics
series.
Because when it
comes to security,
you can't let bad actors win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]